[Musique]
depuis très très longtemps j'ai la
chance et l'habitude de vous
j'ai un peu partout à travers l'afrique
à travers le monde à travers le mali mon
pays
alors ces voyages
ils s'inscrivent dans divers cadres la
chanson depuis plus de 25 ans maintenant
pour présider le premier parlement des
enfants du mali c'était la première
démocratisation de notre pays un honneur
mais c'était pour moi j'avais à peine
dix ans une grande responsabilité mais
une responsabilité qui a façonné toute
ma vie alors il se trouve que même après
mon mariage j'ai la chance quand je me
déplace à travers le monde où l'afrique
ou le mali dans le cadre de mon
engagement citoyen mes enfants ont un
terme
ils appellent cela maman part en mission
alors au début j'ai essayé de leur
expliquer la différence entre mes deux
types de voyages dans le cadre d'une
mission professionnelle ou effectivement
dans le citoyen mais j'ai compris très
vite il rien à faire ils vont pas
comprendre la différence entre les
expliquerait pourquoi je vous parle de
cela mais mon cancer est que même deux
camps nous nous retrouverons que ce soit
au niveau alloue au niveau africain pour
parler de mon continent de notre
continent
on parle de l'afrique de la même manière
on parle de l'africom le corps
on parle de l'afrique comme le continent
où se trouvent les pays les plus pauvres
du monde
je ne veux pas faire de débat là dessus
vous le savez comme moi tout simplement
l'afrique aujourd'hui quand on en parle
c'est un tableau sans et on peut dire
que l'espoir s'amenuise
c'est pas le tableau en tout cas du
continent le plus riche au monde demain
et pourquoi je vais cette question
surtout aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
cette conférence la cour j'ai mené une
réflexion et si je vous disais que bon
il ya eu beaucoup de raisons qui ont été
développés par rapport au sous
développement de la ces raisons ils sont
géographique elles sont culturelles
elles sont historiques
elles sont politiques elles sont parfois
même idéologie et je vais plutôt
m'appesantir sur un cette dernière l'a
et pour vous dire que nous sommes au
21ème siècle encore dans un monde où il
ya toute une communauté
typhi qui attribue le sous développement
de l'afrique deviner à quoi en quelle
raison on manque d'intelligence les
africains c'est très sérieux ce que je
vous dis de nombreux scientifiques très
applaudie et très apprécié par beaucoup
s'en persuader sur la base d'études
scientifiques qu'aujourd'hui l'afrique
n'est pas développé parce que tout
simplement les africains ne sont pas
assez intelligents pour développer leur
continent alors je suis sûr que cela
vous choque comme cela m'a choqué quand
je me suis beaucoup renseigné sur cette
question là au fil des années et je suis
sûr que c'est pas agréable pour nous en
tant qu'africain mais ce que j'aimerais
dire surtout à la jeunesse africaine
c'est important qu'ils s'approprient ce
débat c'est important qu'ils comprennent
que ce débat existe et que ce qui crée
ce débat et l'alimentent ont beaucoup de
pouvoir et c'est important qu'on s'en
approprie pour concentre débarrasse et
pour qu'on comprenne que finalement
c'est un fou au débat
c'est un débat qui est là qui a été fait
est créé et poncet pour nous dominer
mais ça reste un pur fodé baro la
question de l'intelligence
quand on en parle les systèmes de mesure
de l'intelligence qui existent ils sont
fondés sur un monde occidental sur des
modèles occidentaux et pas un modèle
africain
on ne peut pas parler d'intelligence
quand les mesures de l'intelligence qui
existent ne sont en rien fondées sur les
réalités africaines
donc ils sont complètement à côté de la
plaque
et d'ailleurs quand on parle
d'intelligence
elle l'est par éditeur l'intelligence
tout comme la bêtise elle et par éditeur
c'est pour ça que dans l'histoire on a
eu des picasso on a eu engine
on a eu des pasteurs j'en passe mais est
ce que vous avez entendu que de
génération à génération leurs enfants
leurs petits-enfants
il reste les génies mais non l'histoire
nous a démontré que non et c'est pour ça
que l'histoire s'est renouvelé et que
dans cette même histoire du monde
les africains ont eu un rôle à jouer
c'est un faux débat parce que avant la
colonisation dans nos différents états
ça se passait bien les choses se
passaient bien
la progression elle était assez normal
et moi je me rappelle je viens du mali
quand on parlait avant de tombouctou
tombouctou
c'était la ville de la connaissance et
du savoir le monde entier venaient
chercher la connaissance à tombouctou
évidemment aujourd'hui quand on parle de
tombouctou malheureusement ce n'est plus
le cas mais il ne faut pas que la
jeunesse africaine oublie ces moments et
ses réalités ses vérités de notre
histoire
donc ce débat reste un faux débat mais
pourquoi il est très important
pourquoi il est important pour la
jeunesse il est important parce qu'il
faut qu'on regarde la réalité en face
les africains que nous sommes nous avons
développé au fil de l'histoire
un vrai complexe d'infériorité et ce
complexe
il existe en chacun de nous qu'on le
veuille ou non il a existé à un moment
donné de notre vie ce complexe
d'infériorité
il prouve ce complexe d'infériorité que
quelque part nous avons été façonné par
ce type d'idéologie scientifique que
j'ai cités tout à l'heure ce complexe
d'infériorité
il n'est pas nouveau au fil de notre
histoire de l' esclavage
il était là au moment de la colonisation
il était là et même après la
colonisation des africains en ont conclu
que ben finalement vu que l'afrique
s'est fait être colonisé vu que l'
esclavage
nous nous étions du moment que de
mauvais côté de l'histoire
ben finalement ça veut peut-être dire
que nous ne sommes pas les plus
intelligents mais comprennent que c'est
faux et archi faux
et ce complexe d'infériorité
il me rappelle en fait et non dont j'ai
fait la connaissance en tout cas dans
les livres qui s'appelle idriss berkane
idriss berkane et est spécialiste en
neurosciences cognitives idriss berkane
je retiens une chose de lui et j'ai eu
la chance de le connaître grâce à un
superbe formidable professeur de
marketing que j'ai eu il ya 17 ans de
cela qui m'a beaucoup appris et il dit
ceci il nous parle de la théorie de
l'éléphant la théorie de l'éléphant
c'est laquelle il nous explique que dans
l'antiquité
il n'y avait pas de faire on prenait
tout simplement une petite corde pour
attacher à une patte de l'éléphant et
avec cette petite porte
l'éléphant bébé il grandissait jusqu'à
l'âge adulte avec cette pensée que il ne
peut pas se libérer avec cette pensée
qu'il était esclave de cette corde
et pourtant dieu seul sait vous savez
comme moi la force et l'intelligence de
l'éléphant l'éléphant est symbolisée
comme la force et la mémoire et
l'intelligence mais jusqu'à aujourd'hui
ce que je vous dis ce n'est pas une
anecdote cela
étaient donc pour attacher et rendre
esclave un éléphant on lui met une
petite corde à la pâte et vous et moi
d'une manière ou d'une autre cette
petite corde elle existe et j'aimerais
juste vous inviter à si on pouvait
fermer nos yeux juste quelques secondes
pensez à un éléphant imaginez que votre
voisin gauche à droite celui de derrière
il est un éléphant
imaginez que vous avez une corde sur la
plage la patte arrière de l'éléphant
imaginer que cette corde
vous avez grandi avec dans l'esprit que
vous ne pouvez pas vous en libérer
vous avez cette carte vous la sentez
cette corde elle est là elle existe
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux et bien
cette corde
nous sommes tous des éléphants adultes
et il ne tient qu'à nous de nous libérer
de cette corde
il ne tient qu'à nous personne d'autre
ne peut nous libérer de cette corde et
avec l'afrique c'est exactement la même
chose il faut que la jeunesse
comprennent que l'afrique
personne ne le développera à notre place
parce que les africains que nous sommes
nous avons été façonné par ce continent
là c'est notre milieu personne mieux que
nous ne peut comprendre les réalités de
notre continent et il faut que nous nous
libérons de 7 chaînes mentales qui
existe chez les africains et personne ne
le fera à notre place et il ya un autre
scientifique qui disait la chose
suivante
la solution aux problèmes de l'afrique
elle est unique il faut tout simplement
laisser les africains régler eux mêmes
leurs problèmes et je partage
entièrement cette assertion
et c'est pour ça qu'une expérience de ma
vie m'a beaucoup frappé pas parce que
l'expérience en elle-même a eu le mérite
d'exister
il s'agit de la rencontre en 2010 à
l'initiative du président obama avec les
jeunes leaders africains parce qu'il
nous a expliqué ceci il a estimé que les
50 prochaines années à venir c'est la
jeunesse africaine qui fera ce continent
là et que c'était plus important pour
lui de rencontrer cette jeunesse
africaine
écoutez et c'est là où c'est intéressant
d'écouter venant de la jeunesse les
enjeux qu'ils rencontrent dans leurs
états et les solutions qu'il préconise
pour relever ces défis là et c'est ce
message là il faut que le monde accepte
et comprennent que pour développer
l'afrique
il faut des solutions africaines mais
ceci dit cela ne se fera pas tout seul
c'est pas comme un don de dieu dieu même
nous dit je pense que ça se dit dans le
monde entier aide toi le ciel t'aidera
ça ne se fera pas comme par miracle il
faut qu'on réalise notre potentiel
il faut qu'on soit conscient que
l'afrique regorge de potentialités et
d'atouts et il pas remise des
potentialités et ce potentiel
il y en a un qui est unique à l'afrique
c'est le dividende démographique oui le
dividende démographique qu'on veut nous
faire passer comme une menace
d'abord pour notre continent et ensuite
une menace pour le monde
non le dividende démographique c'est
notre plus grande force dans moins de 30
ans on sera plus de 2 milliards
d'africains donc près de 80% sont des
jeunes en 2030
l'afrique aura une mais deux plus élevé
que la chine est en 2050 la plus élevée
au monde
c'est une richesse notre richesse
ressources humaines et c'est notre plus
grande richesse
parce que c'est cette richesse qui nous
permettra de nous engager
l'engagement l'engagement qui constitue
le fil conducteur de toutes mes actions
de toutes les initiatives que j'ai eu la
chance et l'honneur de mettre en oeuvre
depuis maintenant plus de 25 ans et
l'engagement
il tient à chacun de nous
l'engagement chacun doit après avoir
réalisé son potentiel et après avoir
brisé la chaîne réalisé que chacun à son
niveau peut apporter sa petite
contribution
et c'est grâce à cet engagement comptera
l'afrique et c'est grâce à cet
engagement que l'afrique sera un jour et
bientôt le continent le plus riche au
monde et l'engagement
j'aimerais à ce titre je ne peux pas ne
pas le faire reconnaître les actions de
l'association pour le développement de
l'afrique
parce que au mali
des jeunes ont compris leur rôle qu'ils
ont à jouer des jeunes s'engagent ils
organisent chaque année un camp qui
s'appelle le canada de leadership jeunes
et ce qu'on regroupe chaque année des
jeunes venant de tout le pays
les dix régions de notre pays et grâce à
cela
au sortir du camp de leadership il
s'engage au sein de leur communauté au
sein d'un club ohada et ils perpétuent
leur engagement pour toujours il
s'engage et pour ma part je reviens à
l'anecdote dont je vous ai parlé au
début de mes enfants
en fait comme on le dit la vérité sort
de la bouche des enfants
je ne connaissais pas le sens de mon
engagement je le faisais juste tout
naturellement parce qu'à dix ans je me
suis retrouvé à la tête d'une
institution qui prouvaient au delà de la
bonne foi de nos autorités
des vraies actions concrètes mais
finalement quand il parle de mission
c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
cet engagement citoyen et ma mission et
c'est en cela que j'invite chaque jeune
africain chaque jeune malien à s'engager
et pour terminer je dirai que s'engager
et pour passer à l'action
il n'y a pas de moment parfait le
meilleur moment c'est aujourd'hui et je
finis sur une citation qui nous dit que
le meilleur moment pour planter un arbre
c'était il ya 20 ans mais le bon moment
pour le faire
c'est aujourd'hui je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]